a moment of silence if you please all
right that'll do face the Raven this is
your one and only spoiler warning I
don't do spoiler free anymore still here
all right let's get immediately to the
elephant in the room Clara may she rest
in peace
it has been a long time since we have
had a companion death never in the
course of modern era Doctor Who I
suppose if you want to stretch it a
little bit you could argue Amy and worry
but I mean dying of old age just not
traveling with the doctor anymore not
quite the same thing as this for me I've
gone on record multiple times that I've
been done with Clara since before the
series even started so I'm not exactly
gonna say I am sorry to see her go and
actually I kind of saw it coming
pretty much the instant she got that
tattoo she took it from rigsy and that
number count down the back of her neck
just to her attitude that she was so
sure this was a good idea that this was
safe but she was playing with life and
death I'm like I don't think she's gonna
make it out of this alive so I hope that
you realize the fact that I have been
ready for her to leave for a while that
I saw it coming about midway through the
episode but I still think this is a
really well-done death there's a lot
that I like about this starting with now
that we know the circumstances of how
she died looking back all before
shadowing there was to to this I mean
the big thing that I can think of was in
the under the lake before the flood
two-parter and there was one point in
that story where the doctor looks at her
very plain is like to stop trying to be
me which was I think a very deliberate
bit of foreshadowing but it even reaches
further back from that now I don't think
they've been planning for her to die
earlier than that I mean word was that
what happened in the last Christmas was
planned as her exit but then they tacked
on the extra vanity and when she decided
she wasn't gonna leave yet so I don't
think that earlier stuff that we saw in
series 8 was actually planned to
foreshadow to her eventual death but I
think they figured out at that
allow them to reach into things for the
back and habit seem like foreshadowing
because in series 8
there were various points where she
really kind of took on the role of the
doctor you could see her trying to be
him trying to emulate him and at one
point even claiming that she was him I
mean granted it was a bit of subterfuge
in that instance but you look back at
all of that it's like yeah this has been
leading up to this kind of end for her
and I really like what she says to the
doctor that she tells him not to take
revenge because good if any doctor
needed to be told don't lash out as a
result of this he needed to be told that
and that sort of were her understanding
of him which is the very thing that led
to her dying also just really feeds into
this moment very well because she's like
I know you're gonna be sad I know you're
gonna be angry you should not be
traveling alone it's not good for you
and I really hope that he takes all this
to heart cuz I don't want him in the
wake of Clara dying to be too much of a
repeat of David Tennant wet after Donna
was gone where he's just on his own you
see him sort of going a little bit
further and further and darker and
darker than where he should be I mean
compelled he's dark enough as it is so I
I kind of don't necessarily want to see
that taking and I think her ordering him
to basically not do that gives us a very
good reason why he won't go down that
path even though it's logical for him to
because he's gonna honor what she said
to him at least I hope he is now as much
as I did like all of that I do have to
say that her actual death was it was a
little cheesy bass is the point from
which she stepped out of that door onto
the street and everything went into slow
motion and the music swirled up if it
was a little overdone it didn't kill the
moment but it did honestly take some of
the power out of it
for me and how badly the show just felt
like it was shaking me and going cry
damn it but overall I have to say that
that was a really wonderfully handled
death now that's not the only thing that
goes on in this episode we get a
shoulder back again or me or whatever
you want to call her just get
highlighted in this one as much as she
did last time we saw her but I mean
ultimately becomes an episode about
Clara dying so I mean having her being
the highlight would
get away from that so it makes sense I
like the way she was integrated
especially on the note at which things
end between her and the doctor I really
do hope that we get to see her at least
one more time have her show up once in
series 10 I would really appreciate that
Racine was good and was fine but
honestly he didn't bring a ton to the
table it could have been anybody I think
they just picked rigsy because logística
like well he's got the number you can
call them cool that makes it easy that
said I do really like the the spray
paint job he gave to the TARDIS I has
the little sort of post note on the
whole thing I think the whole mystery
aspect of the story to be Oh before it
all sort of gets overtaken with Clara
set which again not a criticism but the
the earlier aspects like what is going
on and why is it going on and how did
this happen and obviously I mean we're
left hanging you know where was the
doctor sent to why who sent him there
and I'm really gonna be excited to find
out the answers to that I like the idea
of that sort of street in general you
know this sort of safe haven for aliens
given that we were already dealing with
Zygons hiding in plain sight it feels
slightly redundant to that but and they
kind of addressed that by having your
shoulder I actually kind of point out
you know we do would you rather we were
like the Zygons and just out there work
we could cause havoc so it helped that
they made that distinction there are
lots of little touches mostly visual
that no yo-yo across this episode that I
really like - the little flashes that
the guys who looked like police were in
fact Judoon or here's something I wonder
if anybody else caught that sort of
stasis field that the the woman that was
supposedly murdered was being kept in
that looked an awful lot like the
masters prison in the Doctor Who TV
movie the the one that Paul McGann was
the doctor in I don't know if that was
intentional but I really hope it was so
I guess the question that I'll throw out
there is what for you has been the
saddest companion eggs and not
necessarily death and it doesn't have to
be in the modern era in the entirety of
Doctor Who that you have seen what do
you feel was the saddest exit for a
companion for me it's not gonna be Clara
because while I think this death was
handled very well I know I wasn't sorry
to see her go so didn't make me cry I
did for me it's probably Donna but I
let's hear from you
saddest companion exit whatever it is
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it
next time this council is adjourned